so we're up here on the living roof of
the Academy now it's planted with over
1.7 million native California plants
there are seven Hills up on this roof a
reference to the seven hills of San
Francisco
the two biggest hills this one here
houses the rain forest and the other big
hill houses the planetarium dome will be
conducting a couple different scientific
studies up here over time we have
entomologists will be studying the
insects that are attracted to the roof
we're also clearing a test patch over
there right now so that we can monitor
which species are coming to the roof on
their own and that will tell us what are
some of the most problematic invasive
species around Golden Gate Park
you can see the sky lights on the roof
over the rainforest here these round
skylights help to get natural sunlight
down to the rainforest plants that are
growing below they also are part of the
natural ventilation scheme for the
building so as hot air builds up inside
the building the statics are triggered
to open so the hot air can be vented out
through the tops of the domes the hills
that you see are also part of the
natural ventilation scheme for the
building just like in nature cool air
drains down the slopes of these hills
and drops into the open piazza at the
center of the building at piazza is
normally open so the cool air drops down
windows open and funnel that fresh air
out onto the exhibit floor and that
allowed us to build the exhibit floor
without any air-conditioning if it's
raining however the weather stations
that are up here on the roof will tell
the skylights to close they'll also tell
a rain screen to slide up over the
piazza and keep that space dry right
around the perimeter of this roof is a
canopy that extends for 30 feet and that
canopy is embedded with 60,000
photovoltaic cells those solar cells
will help us generate up to 10 percent
of our energy in the building the little
black boxes that you can see up here are
actually motion sensors that helps us to
make sure that no one's walking around
up on the roof when they're not supposed
to be
you